side for like 15 seconds and then walk
back out with it with the fake gun in
his hand like I saw the holster drop
newly released body camera video shows
an officer-involved shooting in
Washington state after the suspect
called 9-1-1 threatening to kill someone
the shooting happened on July 4th in
Lacey Washington about an hour Southwest
of Seattle officials with the Grays
Harbor Sheriff's Office were dispatched
to a home on the city's northeast side
after a man called 9-1-1 reporting a
domestic violence incident the caller
told dispatch police needed to respond
right away before he killed someone body
camera video shows First Responders make
their way to the scene
[Music]
thank you
the video recording capture sheriff's
deputies saying they've been to this
home before
I've been here before
yeah
I haven't been here for a while where
are you going bud
officials on the scene speak with a man
and woman before the suspect pulls out a
weapon after that one of the deputies
opens fire immediately officials Rush
inside
as First Responders rushed to the
suspect he yells out saying he doesn't
have a weapon
oh
I don't have anything man I swear to God
I don't have anything man fly flat lie
flat on the ground straight out all
right all right
I swear to God man are you shot I don't
know I think
oh
I don't have anything else
Sean I don't have anything man we're
bleeding it's not real the man continues
to say he isn't armed later telling
officials he dropped what was in his
hand as soon as the deputy raised his
gun
lift up to your knees go up go up go up
First Responders then check to see
whether the man is injured
okay where's this Blood okay we got to
get everything off
yep
you got my pants off just take them off
now we got to make sure are you we're
concerned about your health dude I don't
care about you you're bleeding from the
hand or somewhere on the hand so we're
trying to figure this out I think it's
glass
I my right hand is nominal okay that's
we're checking here dude you gotta get
it all off all right I think you're okay
I think I think I'm all right
officials determined the man had minor
injuries saying a bullet ricocheted off
his body
I don't have anything you gotta hit
right there all right what's that a
Ricochet okay I don't know
radio one boy 35. I think you got me in
the arm
Ricochet off the chest
we're still still searching sheriff's
deputies then head outside to begin
securing the scene
uh we're setting up a crime scene
perimeter
right there the whole driveway everyone
out of the driveway
he doesn't like to be shot
he has a little bit of a lot of hand
maybe hit from a Ricochet but there's no
like puncture video shows First
Responders putting up crime scene tape
and marking where shell casings were
discharged
can you give me a couple markers so I
can start marking shells
I'm just marking shells yeah
yep I'm actually staying on that side of
the car because Graves was roughly here
ish when it went down so if she just
stays on that side she needs to stay for
interviews she's having fam someone come
get her kids
here I don't want 23 in there alone
yep yep send them out we have enough
here
huh
and then oh no no yeah I see what you're
doing you're doing great Draya thank you
don't watch yourself show there just go
see your car and turn on the AC thank
you Sean
thank you so much
the recording then shows EMS responders
arrived to the scene
uh it'll be straight up the stairs
foreign
as more Sheriff's officials arrive
initial responders describe what
happened
we were just shown up with him on the
call what we saw okay she was out front
like uh I saw him who's standing here
because he was when I call him like hey
bud what's going on just turns out
walking and then he shooted us he had a
fake gun that he drew from a holster
okay and then Graves great I didn't see
because I was on the other side I saw
the holster drop okay and then we went
inside the house like I could see the
fake gun on the ground okay did we shoot
in here yes okay
great that that's it in a nutshell
so it's a Ricochet yeah it's great it's
not there's no penetration it's not even
actively bleeding
yes but you could definitely tell a
lifted swelling and a graze Mark
um we're still trying to locate casings
right now EMS responders then medically
clear the man but officials still demand
he be taken to the hospital
all right
let me check with the supervisor
uh Benji can you go start a crime scene
log thank you for all your help we
appreciate everything you're doing yeah
do you have that paperwork for a crime
scene log uh
okay thank you
um
fire says he's perfectly healthy but for
liability purposes do we still want to
send him to the hospital yes yes okay
a fire
yes transport
yes
sheriff's deputies then discussed the
suspect's weapon they say it was fake
inside for like 15 seconds and then
walked back out with it with the fake
gun in his hand like I saw the holster
drop drop to the ground I didn't see it
get pointed I was
to the left of the bottom of stairs to
the left I saw the holster drop on the
ground Graves yell
um
I can't remember 100 is like Drop It
Something To indicate I knew gun
and then her shots
and at that point starts screaming it's
fake it's fake what are you doing
no it's a big gun
buy grapes
by Graves oh investigators say this
suspect was taken to the hospital and
treated for minor injuries he was later
booked and charged with two counts of
assault in the second degree days later
he was released from jail after it was
determined he was quote not an immediate
risk to himself or to others
right now the suspect's name is not
being released publicly the shooting is
still under investigation by the Region
3 critical incident investigation team
once that investigation is complete the
results will be handed over to the
Thurston County prosecutor reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie